good afternoon everyone
i'm dr miller and today we're not going
to be covering a specific anomaly
but rather a broader type of anomaly
that we at the foundation have observed
over the years
this anomaly has many names but the most
common term adopted by foundation
researchers
is reality bender or type greens by goc
operatives the following document seized
by mobile task force delta 5
is part of a larger case file on the
global occult coalition
this section is an excerpt from a
publication entitled
physics division field manual 13 special
circumstances
humanoid threat entities
type green reality bender
introduction reality benders type greens
have a certain mystique among goc
operatives
some operatives even argue that it is
impossible to terminate a type green
and that is suicide to even try the kill
record of our organization says
otherwise
the key to terminating type green
entities lies in finding and taking
advantage of their few weaknesses
in 95 percent of cases greens cannot
predict the future and can be taken by
surprise
have limited range and cannot affect
what they cannot perceive
they cannot impose their will on
anything if they have no will to impose
and have human foibles that can be
manipulated emotionally
and or rationally sequence
99 of type greens undergo the following
sequence of psychological changes
as their powers progress phase one
denial the subject refuses to
acknowledge their ability to warp
reality
the type green will attempt to
rationalize away their abilities by
various means
in some cases the type green will end
here their ability will
be self-suppressed and they will not
proceed
however most then proceed to phase two
experimentation the subject acknowledges
their abilities and begins to test the
limits of their powers
in general type greens tend to
experiment in one of two patterns
slowly methodically and carefully
advancing a small amount at a time
or in a small number of sudden jumps in
any case the subject will generally
remain in this mode for some time
before proceeding to phase three
stability
the subject reaches the limit of their
powers and determines the boundaries of
their abilities
the type green achieves control over
their reality shifts
and can manipulate them as necessary
more importantly they can choose not to
utilize their abilities
if needed phase 3 is normally
characterized by
attempts to live a normal life the
subject will continue in normal routines
and aside from necessary precautions to
prevent losing control
will utilize their abilities only in
private and only in a manner that will
not
harm others these type greens may be
classified as threat level 1
monitor do not engage but should be
monitored closely due to the risk of
proceeding to
phase 4 the child god
sadly the majority of type greens will
eventually progress
to phase four during this phase the
reality bender becomes obsessed with the
power it possesses
and will attempt to utilize it for
personal gain at the cost of others
this phase is marked by reduced empathy
for other humans
inability to accept personal faults and
increased megalomania
although warning signs are numerous the
key aspect of a phase 4 is the use of
their abilities to manipulate
other humans teenage and young adult
type greens will typically use their
abilities for sexual purposes
while children will attempt to make
strangers their friends
older adults may attempt to manipulate
others for love
or financial gain although a few cases
have resulted where the type green then
reverts to phase 3
99 of them will remain at phase 4 until
eliminated
for this reason phase 4 type greens
should be considered threat level 5
immediate threat and eliminated
immediately
as they represent a major threat to all
aspects of the fivefold mission
termination any attempt to eliminate a
type green
must take into consideration the three
factors for
dynamic entry in close quarter battle
speed type greens are able to quickly
react to
any threat in order to ensure a
successful kill
the operation must take no longer than
one second from initiation of hostiles
to
termination of subject this is the
average time it takes for a human being
to reflexively react to an unexpected
threat
or event surprise
type greens are able to quickly adapt to
known threats
it is recommended that a bluff play be
carried out
an overt threat is to be presented to
the subject for them to
fixate upon while the actual kill is
carried out from an unexpected direction
violence of action the kill method
chosen to eliminate a type green
must ensure a successful termination on
the first
shot sniper weapons should utilize large
caliber rounds
preferably hollow point for maximum
expansion
or armor piercing as needed firearms are
of course
a secondary kill choice explosives are
recommended
but may not be usable due to collateral
damage risks
if firearms must be used multiple
shooters
should be present and all should aim for
head shots if possible or
center torso shots if necessary
example names have been redacted for
security purposes
subject alpha alice was a 90 year old
caucasian woman
living on a farmhouse in town a anytown
usa
alice first came to the attention of the
goc following reports of ghosts haunting
the fields outside her town
initial covert investigation was able to
rule out the presence of
actual spectral entities through veritas
scanning
further investigation was approved a goc
special observer
oscar proceeded to any town with a full
support team
posing as the cast and crew of the
reality television program
ghost finders incorporated subject alice
was discovered to be living alone with
two cats she had been widowed for three
years prior
and her children all lived out of state
subject alice proved personable and
charming
and often engaged the operatives in
conversation and provided them with tea
and home-baked cookies oscars soon
determined over the course of the next
few days
that alice was the proximal cause of the
apparitions
as they only appeared when alice was
either asleep or not
present upon engaging her in further
conversation
he discovered that she was a lapsed
catholic now agnostic
who expressed a desire to believe in an
afterlife but was not satisfied by her
faith
agent oscar theorized that alice was a
subconscious type
green who was expressing her grief over
her husband's death
by manifesting apparitions of his ghost
following a lengthy philosophical
discussion including a discussion of
pascal's wager
the apparitions increased in strength
and clarity
allowing oscar to obtain a clear
photograph of the entity
he then presented the photograph to
alice for identification
to his surprise alice identified the
photograph
not as her husband but as subject me
bob a young man with whom she had been
acquainted during her younger years
alice claimed that she and bob had been
romantically involved in the early 1940s
but their relationship had been
suspended when bob was drafted into the
second world war
during that war alice made the
acquaintance of her eventual husband
a factory worker who had been classified
4f due to a leg injury caused by an
automobile accident
two days after bob received her dear
john letter he was killed in normandy
during operation overlord
alice's heightened emotional state
caused the apparitions to increase in
frequency
and intensity including physical
manifestations
after a goc operative was injured by a
luger bullet fired by one of the ghosts
central ordered termination of the
subject
operative oscar requested permission to
attempt a non-lethal
soft kill citing second mission
concealment concerns
permission was granted no record remains
of operative oscar's subsequent
conversation with subject alice
but it convinced the subject to manifest
an apparition of bob that night
the first time that she had manifested
an apparition in her own presence
after receiving emotional closure with
what she believed was the spectral
entity of her old lover
the apparitions ceased manifesting
entirely
subject died three nights later in her
sleep of natural causes
no further paranormal phenomena have
occurred in the area since subject
alice's death
operative oscar was commended for his
actions
afternoon everyone have a seat get a cup
of coffee and a muffin
also a reminder the seminar rooms are a
weapons-free zone
please make sure you've surrendered your
weapons at the reception desk
i know it's [ __ ] but the last thing
i need is an o5 complaining because one
of you was walking around the blue zones
with your piece
everyone good cool
today's seminar is a subject near and
dear to my heart
reality benders type greens mary sues
bixby's shapers wizards gods devils
outside observers call them what you
will
these are the guys that change reality
based on perception
and willpower i've made a career out of
both containing
and killing these guys you're here to
get certified to do the same thing
want to know my secret
[Laughter]
we'll get to that later first of all i
want you to take a look at the doors to
the seminar room
notice something about them look again
what doors yes the doors are gone
take a closer look if you want touch
them they're not there
the doors have literally disappeared but
that's okay
right you can still get out the windows
if you want
except there's one small problem there
aren't any windows in this room either
are there all the windows are gone
there's nothing but four blank walls a
ceiling and a floor
no way out but how did you get in
starting to free down a bit don't worry
just take a deep breath you're gonna be
all right
just a bit of a change to the way the
room's set up it's not like anything
worse is happening
i mean it could be worse right
at least you're safe in here it's not
like the desks are coming alive to kill
you now is it
oh wait yes they are the
desks are going to kill you what are you
going to do
how are you going to survive the goddamn
room is alive and going to eat you
watch for those desks they've got teeth
get them
away from there now you want to live
you're going to have to fight
don't try to deny it you [ __ ]
this is real
this is happening this is a reality bend
and you're going to die unless you can
fight it
is that gun really gonna do anything
against the reality bender
i can turn your goddamn bullets into
sand
i can turn your eyes into jello i can
turn your gun into a fighting bagel
now put that damn gun down
[Music]
what do i want what do i want
[Music]
eternity there is no escape no respite
you live when i say live you die
if i allow it and there is nothing left
but my imagination
all right hit the lights
everyone breathe in and out deep
breathe in breathe out
breathe in breathe
out you feeling better now
let me tell you what just happened each
and every one of you
has just had a bad trip all of the food
on that back table was laced with a
powerful hallucinogen
it's my own personal recipe in addition
to hallucinations
it renders one very susceptible to
suggestion
combined with some simple hypnosis and
some special effects trickery
the end result is as close as we can get
to showing you what a reality bender's
attack
feels like the support staff are pumping
in an aerosolized counter agent into the
air vents as we speak
it's gonna feel like [ __ ] in a moment
you'll find barf bags under your chairs
take a moment to let it all out
i want you to reflect back on that
moment when you realized what was
happening
do you remember that feeling of
helplessness
do you remember what it felt like to
realize the reality no longer existed
and you were nothing but toys for a
hostile will that controlled
everything remember that and hold on to
it
the first time you're about to go up
against a reality bender
if you ever think that maybe you can
contain them or
maybe they can be reasoned with remember
what it felt like when you were tripping
balls
and nothing was real then
kill that mother before he knows you're
even there you're all certified now
class dismissed
i would like to give a special thank you
to
onyx arbiter soul
the morrigan retalias
karim el ashmoy patrick bailey
dreams boy that ain't right
matthew gilmore eric corbeage
kawaii fire keeper joker corvus
king madding james saba
and nj vojak if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vogue thank you
you